la tasa de cambio unitaria de g con
respecto a x es la cantidad que cambia
por un cambio de una unidad en x la tasa
de cambio unitaria de ye con respecto a
x es menor en la ecuación de 6.5 x o en
la gráfica de bajo cuando nos hablan de
la tasa de cambio unitaria podría ser un
poco ambiguo pero en esta pregunta
podemos ver que nos están hablando sobre
la tasa de cambio unitaria d con
respecto a x o cuánto cambia en un
cambio de x o sea cuando x tiene un
incremento de una unidad y aquí podemos
ver que cuando x cambia en una unidad
que cambia en 6.5 cada vez que x se
incrementa en 1 que se va a incrementar
en 6.5 o podríamos decir que la tasa de
cambio unitaria de ye con respecto a x
es de 6.5 para cada cambio de x en una
unidad en la gráfica que tenemos aquí
cuando x cambia en 1 o sea cuando x se
incrementa en 1 que se incrementa en 3.5
más o menos
lo que vemos aquí x se incrementa en 1 y
ye se incrementa en 3.5 así que la tasa
de cambio unitaria aquí en esta gráfica
de jay con respecto a x es de 3.5 para
cada cambio de x en una unidad que se
incrementa en 3.5 entonces vemos que
esta línea se incrementa en una tasa
menor que en esta ecuación y en esta
línea se incrementa en una tasa de
cambio unitaria menor que el incremento
que tiene en esta ecuación con respecto
a x
la tasa unitaria es menor en la gráfica